[Music]
hi and welcome to episode number 65 of
the weekly Google cloud platform podcast
I am Francis campoy and I'm here with my
colleague mark Mandel hey Mark how are
you doing I'm good it feels like we did
an episode just yesterday it is crazy
it's been so long with a recording an
episode yeah and we are today at moscone
west here in San Francisco for Google
Cloud next yeah Jing it's been pretty
crazy it is a huge huge huge event and
we've had some fantastic people coming
by at the booth to come do some short
interviews with us it's been an amazing
day there's so many people that we
interviewed all of them amazing there's
so many of them that we will not be able
to show all of the people that we talked
to which is which is okay there's also a
bunch of things that will not be able to
discuss but you should definitely check
out the news because there's so many
cool announcements ya know you should
totally tuned in the keynote should be
available for for watching the keynotes
already online we'll have a show note we
have a link on the show notes so go
check it out there's the keynote there's
all the announcements linear first
there's made much much much much stuff
so yeah go check those out and instead
we're we're gonna try to give you to you
today is an inside view of what's going
on here at naga so speaking of keynote
the first person we interview today
sarah robinson developer advocate part
of our team the amazing sir Robinson
amazing Robertson did an amazing demo
and so why don't we go chat to her and
talk to her about all the things she was
involved with in the keynote sounds good
let's do that fresh off the stage from
the keynote we are I'm just delighted to
be joined by Sir Robinson a member of a
DEA team did an amazing job at the
keynote this morning how you doing today
thank you it's great to be here it was
fun a little scary but super fun that
was amazing that was when out really
well yeah yeah absolutely um so if
anyone for whatever reason doesn't know
who you are can you tell us a little bit
about yourself sure my name is sarah
robinson I'm a developer advocate on the
cloud team with mark and France asked
so as DA's we get to build demos give
talks about them write blog posts and
I'm focused on big data and machine
learning nice and gives a little bit
about the demoed you gave today sure so
the demo was of a new API that we
launched at the keynote this morning
called the video intelligence API which
lets you basically get granular data on
what's in your video so you send it a
video and it gives you back high level
data some labels on what's this video
about and then it also returns labels
for each seen in the video it'll tell
you different entities that it finds so
could say oh there's a dog in this scene
from second one two three and it gives
you that data throughout your entire
video it was this kind of similar like
vision API but for basically video
exactly yes if you're familiar with the
vision API which gives you metadata on
images this does that for video which
makes it easy to search a large library
of video content pretty easily to find
the exact scenes you're looking for so
what was the actual demo you did on
stage so that demo was an app that I
built with another developer and is
actually a node.js app that runs on
Google App Engine and it uses cloud
functions under the hood lots of google
cloud technology coming into play so the
way it works is there is a Google Cloud
Storage bucket with all the videos when
you add a video to that bucket there's a
cloud function listening that sends a
video to the video API and then writes
the JSON response back to a separate
Cloud Storage bucket so the app is not
calling the video API directly it just
calls it just the front end it retrieves
the video metadata from the cloud
storage bucket and then the associated
annotations and displays them and it
makes it super easy to implement search
because you are you have all that
annotation data in your JSON response so
you can search your video library find
the exact clips you're looking for it's
definitely fun demo to build it looked
really really great yeah I was actually
thinking about I don't know if you know
the literal video version what a literal
video version is it's like basically you
show video clips but instead of having
the the song you have the song
description of what the video is showing
instead of what the music is normally I
always thing is like it that'd be an
amazing them
for this feature yeah something we
thought about doing but thought it might
be too much for the keynote was as the
video plays kind of have the labels
bubble up that are going at that's at
that point in time that basical might
add that later will definitely continue
to use this demo tweak it take it on the
road very cool so other than your
amazing demo and the keynote in general
what are you excited about for the rest
of the of the conference yeah so I'm
actually doing a session tomorrow which
will cover the video API in more detail
yes but it's focused on all the machine
learning api's that we have so it'll be
five in total video vision speech
natural language and translation and
that is tomorrow at eleven yeah London
twenty eleven twenty great other
sessions there's lots of great sessions
on Big Data I know Felipe's doing one on
public data sets and bigquery some other
machine learning ones some deep dives
into cloud ml engine and also marks
session right yeah mark session you
don't even know my sis do you I know
it's with a customer there we go that's
fine that's fine is your session at
tomorrow afternoon at four okay great
what's it on I'm talking about building
large-scale persistent world to learn
our partner it's improbable wow that
sounds really fun I'm actually gonna be
there to watch the demo because I think
it's gonna be pretty cool yep awesome
well Sarah thank you so much for taking
the time in such a busy day for you to
talk about like all the cool things that
you've seen today thanks for having me
Thanks thank you so thanks again to
Sarah for taking some time today and
coming to chat with us her demo the
keynote the whole thing about everything
she did was fantastic that was an
amazing amazing demo I mean the product
itself is cool is an amazing thing yeah
but the demo was so well done so
congratulations are you rock yeah and
speaking of amazing things and amazing
people we also had the absolute pleasure
of having the director of engineering at
YouTube yeah I mean visit us as well
yeah so Mia subramanian decided to join
us after a panel she was doing and she's
here to talk to us about the content of
the panel but also a little bit about
what is
to be a engineering director Google ya
know she came she did a panel about
diversity in tech and has succeed with
University in tech and why it's actually
so important apparently it was amazing
as well we should definitely check out
the recording for that oh yeah so um why
don't we go talk to some young so I'm
good led to that and we're very happy
now to welcome so Mia subrahmanyan
engineer at Google to the podcast girl
pop up from podcasts how are you doing
so Mia I'm doing good we're very happy
to have you you just finished a pretty
cool session but before we talk about
that session you were on why don't you
tell us a little bit a little bit about
what you do at Google sure um I'm a
director of engineering at Google and I
leave the engineering efforts for
YouTube music that is free ma that's
pretty amazing but that's not a small
project obviously like that now it's why
didn't come yes go could you tell us a
little bit about what doesn't tell to be
director of engineering yeah so at
YouTube being a director of engine I
mean at Google when you're leading up an
engineering team that entails a lot of
different things starting from figuring
out what is the team doing was the
mission of your team to really figuring
out your kind of architecture and design
technical architecture and design as
well as what your org design looks like
like making sure you have the right
people on the team and you are scaling
your resources your people your
technology in the right way and really
it's pretty cross-functional you're
working very closely with your product
management team and your UX and the
business partners awesome now I know you
were part of a session today or leading
a session today what were you doing here
yeah the reason I'm here at the
conference is I was on a panel I was a
panelist at a session around diversity
and impact of diversity two companies
great and
even more than that we had one of your
colleagues a minute ago and she was
telling us about how it was basically
about how to guide women to increase
their success what what was the what was
the whole idea behind the panel what was
the main message yeah I think the main
message of the panel was about how
having more diverse and inclusive
thinking diverse and inclusive teams
really affects the bottom line for
companies and how you can go about
looking at both your business models as
well as the people that you work with in
ways where you're shifting the thinking
to be more inclusive to drive change
were there any really good techniques or
sort of like ideas or behavioral
practices for getting more diverse teams
that sort of came up in the panel yeah I
think one was one that was kind of
interesting that was called out is
whether you're a startup or a big
company there are challenges to making
that shift happen off different kinds
right and the only way you start
addressing that problem about having a
more diverse team is not just to believe
that a diverse team is impactful but to
actually see that happen and make that
change so I think that's one big thing
which is it's not just a number you're
trying to fill out or make up but it
really does make drive change and impact
and growth that was one big kind of
theme cool very interesting so how many
people were they at the at the panel on
the panel yeah my funnel happy they were
like I think six of us six of you nice
and this all of this was recorded so the
name of the panel do you remember the
actual name of the panel it's okay we'll
find it well fun that we put a link on
the show notes I think it's a very
interesting topic and it is recorded so
we it will be posted on YouTube which
you manage their ego as sometime soon is
there anything else that that you'd like
to mention something you've seen there
in the conference that got you excited
about you happy or something like that
yeah you know I mean
was amazed at how many people are here
at this conference I think this is the
first time for Google Cloud to host this
conference like of this kind of this
size it's pretty amazing to see the
number of attendees here it's really
really exciting I mean we use the cloud
and the infrastructure because all of
our stuff is built on google tree
infrastructure but seeing this make be
made available for other companies and
other businesses to build on and it's
really amazing all right well thank you
so much for taking some time out of your
busy schedule to come and join us here
at our booth and you know if you're
hanging and hang around I hope you have
a great next and thank you again thank
you so much thank you so we go from
amazing women in tech to another amazing
woman tech these time not at Google
she's a SME manager so site reliability
engineering manager at Dropbox yeah I
honestly I actually really love when we
talk about site reliability engineering
it's a fascinating topic it is very cool
and especially she has really
interesting viscous she's sorry manager
at Dropbox where they use the same name
at Google as in Google so they're pretty
similar by the same time not exactly the
same so she's coming to talk a little
bit about what are all the sessions that
she saw they were cool and what she's
excited about talking about cloud and
all the sessions are coming awesome well
let's go talk to her so we are now
joined by Tammy future and amazing human
being that works for dropbox how are you
doing great thanks thanks for having me
yeah thank you for coming we're very
excited to have you we why don't you
tell us a little bit about what you do
at Dropbox yeah I'm a site reliability
engineering manager at Dropbox where I
lead the databases team and also our
magic pocket team which is our block
storage and yeah so very busy I I do to
on-call shifts but you know we're pretty
good at Dropbox it doing a lot of
automation and making sure that
everything is up and running all the
time yeah
yeah really great team of engineers but
you know it's challenging to do that
cool so it sounds like you know very
well about what like sre and stuff like
that you actually use the same name that
which is interesting why didn't you tell
it'll be about like the kind of things
kind of sessions that you're interested
about here I clown next what is like for
a necessary what gets you excited here
yeah so there was some really good
sessions this morning about the history
of sre so yeah sre started at Google
with Brent trainer and he was upstairs
doing a talk which was really cool it's
always good to get to hear him speak
he's amazing yeah he's very good and the
reason that sre was created at Dropbox
was because Andrew phone came from
google he was at YouTube originally okay
and he has been at Dropbox now for over
four years but yeah he took a lot of the
ideas from when he was there and yeah
like next what I'm really excited to see
this afternoon is to learn more about
how Google sre and also the CRE customer
reliability engineers are helping people
use google cloud it's pretty exciting to
me because it is hard like even this
morning I was actually experienced a
website it was very slow I tweeted the
company's I'd like your website is very
slow and then they write back and said
do you want a job i was like no really i
have understand that it's very hard to
do it got really tough to make your
website work well and work all the time
so yeah I'm excited about where the
industry is heading and there's more
ways for people to be supported when
they're trying to build their own
company yeah i think that CRE is exactly
about that like growing a necessary team
not easy as i'm sure you know so having
the possibility of basically getting
like sres a service scanner that is
pretty cool yeah i think it makes sense
we've had one of my teammates paul who
did a rotation with an internal sre team
on the on the podcast and he talks a lot
especially around like SLO is SL a sling
basically how up does your thing have to
be in terms of like how much change you
want to do like you talk about that as
well and how that sort of worked in your
yeah it's just it's really well done at
barks ang like I knew we got a lot of
ideas there's you can also read the sre
book from google like oh yeah it's free
now so yeah yeah that book is awesome
and there's lot of tips in there and
it's similar to what we do at Dropbox
but one of the things that I really love
when i first started Dropbox been there
for a year and a half is we actually
send daily SLA email report is actually
super handy like it sounds so simple but
if you just get that in your inbox every
day and you can see the history today
yesterday like last week the last four
weeks to actually keep track of your
essays and where you're hitting and then
it changes color based on if we're maybe
it could get bad or something like that
so then we can be more proactive that's
quite handy and then we also set up
alerts to alert on SLA like you I think
that's actually super important a lot of
people don't do that they don't actually
track where am I out for my SLA like
morning you know you're getting close
you better actually do something I think
that's very good cool so since you have
you read the SR ebook them yet okay it's
awesome so is there anything that it is
just am shelly different from s re at
Google necessary at Dropbox and one of
the big differences is just the number
of people oh yeah there's like so many
sres at Google our team is quite small
we only have under 40 s eries at Dropbox
so we're pretty little and also we're
not distributed around the world we're
more in San Francisco and Dublin so yeah
we were doing a lot we have 600 million
customers at Dropbox so there's a lot of
people to support we have 500 petabytes
of data more now maybe that bad so
pretty exciting what we do but yeah we
do have very small teams but we took
take a lot of inspiration from what's
happening at Google around automation so
you know we do a lot of self-healing if
something breaks we don't have to
manually do something it automatically
heals itself and so for us it's more
about looking after the automation and
can you can continuing to build new
features and making it even better over
time so yet we just don't want to be
doing like a manual work which you can
have human error there anywhere so it's
not a good idea so I just out of
curiosity like you obviously got a lot
of experience with this if someone's at
a company and they're thinking we should
really start an SRA team is the google
book the best place to start is there
somewhere else what's the what's the
best resources to get started yeah i
really like the book i think it's very
good
you could also look up some of the
videos that Ben's done in the past those
are really great and I've also done a
video to that you can watch um I spoke
at lenox Khan in Australia and I did a
talk on site reliability engineering at
Dropbox well and it goes through what we
actually do there and yeah quite a few
people have watched that and like
learned a lot from it and I think for us
like you know we're always just trying
to improve we're always getting better
things change so fast you know there's
like new hardware all the time you're
building new services you're deprecating
services like you're always trying to
move forward so like I think look for
the newest most relevant content that
comes out and then look for some of the
wise talks from the past that was just
really great yep cool so thank you so
much for taking the time out of your I'm
sure super busy is Kenta leg next and
have a great continuation next and see
you at gopher come for your amazing
opening keynote yeah no wait I'm so
excited for that like thank you very
much thank you thank you hi so I'm very
happy that we have another Australian
coming to grace our podcast they can
never ever be enough Australians she's
rested yeah she's absolutely fantastic I
mean I don't know about Australians but
definitely tell me an amazing person you
have me pop casa thanks again tell me
for coming and sharing your knowledge
yep for the final interview though we
have Claire Bailey this is really cool
because it talks about our code labs
yeah it really kind of also explores
like not only can you see all the videos
at home but there's also like take home
activities you can do at home as well I
think that one of the favorite one of
the favorite things for attendees here
at cloud max is the fact that you can
learn so much you have all the people
surrounding you you have to meet the
experts you have the all the talks but
you also have the code labs yep
important thing you can also do those at
home so Claire is here to tell us
everything about that part of the
conference floor we have Claire Bailey
the global code labs lead who is running
code labs right now at cloud next well
actually not right now she's right now
she's with us right she's that generally
yes Claire how you doing I'm great code
labs kicked off about an hour and a half
ago the tables are pretty full other
than being dragged way to do this
podcast well you're welcome so whether
you tell us a little bit about what
deaths in
tail to be the global collapse lead
pretty much anything that touches code
labs comes through me at some point a
lot of it is stuff like this where
there's on the ground events next I oh
we have a lot of smaller developer
summits as well and code labs are
hands-on technical training exercises we
run them are their self paced and you
just kind of show up and we've got a
computer you can bring your own and
we've got step-by-step instructions and
kind of anything you might want to learn
and you can run through it and learn
something new and we're there to help
you so is this something just at cloud
next or can they do it on their own
elsewhere what's the how's that work
they can definitely do it on their own
elsewhere we have them we have computers
provided at cloud next to do them here
we have Googlers on hand to answer
questions and get stuck but they are
also online so the code labs from next
can be found at Google quick labs com
that's quick labs with a w qwi que el
abs com we'll have a link on the show
notes as usual excellent excellent yeah
google quit labs com for all the code
labs that are at this conference that is
awesome could you tell us a little bit
more about what what what should people
expect to learn from those collabs is
like all about specific topics or what
what is your favorite one oh and I'm a
fan of machine learning to some of the
those in the Big Data ones are probably
my favorites they really run the range
though like there's some very beginner
ones there's one that's just how to set
up a virtual machine oh right yeah which
like some pretty basic level entry level
for cloud all the way through to machine
learning and complicated language
specific right like platform-specific
running this language on this platform
and deploying in this type of server
they get pretty pretty complex to give
you an idea of how to do cloud
operations so it's pretty awesome yeah
so okay so a lot of our listeners
obviously i'm guessing aren't gonna be
here unfortunately which is a shame but
so if they're doing this at home do they
need to set up a free trial how does
that kind of thing work just to set
expectations really they don't as of
this conference this is the first time
we've used this new infrastructure this
quick labs infrastructure it's a company
we acquired a couple months ago with the
quick lab setup you don't have to enter
your own account or your own credit card
at any point they generate accounts for
you that last phone
between half an hour and an hour and a
half depending on how hard the code lab
is nice yeah and then you just run
through it with that so it really is a
simple easy trial with zero commitment
well so for the people that actually
here are we gonna have the code lab all
day is it 24 hours service how does that
work luckily for me they're not going 24
hours they are going from just after the
keynote every day you have to basically
win the sessions end so all three days
there will be code labs ready for you to
stop by and try out sounds awesome
that's really really cool awesome so if
you're here or you're elsewhere and
you're really keen to basically get your
hands on with Google Cloud check out URL
or come to the code labs at the event
awesome well Clara thank you so much for
taking time out of your very busy
schedule yes you come talk with us we
really appreciate it thank you for
having me it's been fun that was an
amazing conversation and I'm actually
very excited about being able myself to
go through those collapse yeah I want to
do them do yeah cuz they're like they're
really cool and we do not really have
the time here at cloud Nexus you know
we're busy period but no we should make
a mention to it if you want to learn
more and you're not here at next you can
do the code labs yourself but there are
also extended events all around the
world yeah they are I think they're like
350 yeah so there's an island life
there's one per country or more than
that like I know that there's many
countries with is plenty of them there
was like I think 80 of them in the
United States so even if you were not
able to travel physically here thanks to
the podcast I hope you're having a
little bit of the inside view and you
can also do all the code labs you can go
watch the keynote ethics and events and
they extended events and not necessarily
at the same dates which means that you
should definitely check it out because
maybe it's next week in a couple weeks
and you still have the chance to join
them yeah just go check out its as
extended on the cloud next URL you can
go there type in your city see what
events are happening in your hometown
that is great well I think that this is
and now for today this is a great great
day lots of really cool things but
there's so much more coming tomorrow
yeah well
we'll see you all tomorrow see y'all
tomorrow
you